this is called the Avon credit card but
it's not like all the other credit cards
Dave because those other credit cards
they're bad bad bad they're unsecured
debt So when you buy a steak you can't
afford
at the restaurant
you lose your home oh there you go
because you pledged collateral
a steak
boom nice trade and that's what they're
saying they're saying wouldn't it be
nice to have a credit card that lets you
use your home equity to get really low
rates it lets you this is a privilege
Dave that we so sweet of them they're so
service minded and I love that it says
you get really really low rates between
7.99 and 14.99 variable interest
better than a credit card is it